we're supposed to all to September angry
okay
that originally came about I believe
Phil had the idea like a very long time
ago to create sort of a news YouTube
platform where it could be like a la
carte and if somebody had a particular
interest in one particular story they
could just watch like a quick video on
it so from that sort of evolved into
what it is now I think that fact I could
be making all of it I think also didn't
I hear the rumor that he fell off of his
toilet trying to hang a picture frame
and he hit his head yeah toilet and then
he drew out the SourceFed logo yeah one
time he couldn't find his kids so he was
having some some whiskey and a like a
bright light came in through the window
yeah and he didn't believe in the bright
light so he said he didn't leaving the
bright light fell dead Tinkerbell that
is Robert we were like going into kpac
just guys we do get toast though oh yeah
basis he shares his toast i I want to
chalk it up to you know friendliness but
it might be low carbs a lot of daily
meetings there's a lot of dealing things
beretta beretta gets a lot of dealing
it's a closed-door policy and I want it
to be open but he won't well and the
weird thing the weird thing for us is is
when when Joe gets called into these
meetings he goes in pretty happy he's
got a lot of energy comes back like an
hour to later he's just got a red face
and it looks like his hair is all mess
no he's good it's good that everything's
good sure he's a great boss no yes he is
kind of like he lets us come up with a
lot of cool ideas and he we have a
freedom to just kind of like try out our
like little ideas yeah there lets us
express ourselves in our own way but
also just kind of like you know we're
doing news here yeah another thing so
you know there's got to be that that
sense of seriousness and yeah but I
think he just does a great job of saying
like look I know you're really
interested in blink so why not try and
run with that like I see that this is
your passion so do something with it but
he also doesn't beat around the bush if
he doesn't like it yeah right
no you're nice because then you you know
I I feel like he really knows what he
wants
yeah that's in this and so that's really
helpful and I think he respects that all
of us are so different and so alike that
he just I think he really embraces that
and kind of you know fosters that
creativity he's our foster dad the
videos that we put out arms typically
wearing that like white orb but because
of that and because there is like a time
crunch and we do have like an insane
amount of creative freedom to take that
and kind of like you know treat it a
little bit like it's a blank canvas and
hopefully I do some fun stuff yeah I
mean literally like come in and do
things like today we're gonna play white
noise cuz it just came out and we're all
gonna get scared shitless and now that's
a video so yeah yeah as long as it gets
the okay from Big Daddy Phil then we
Kenna we can run it we should call him
that now kind of like in the in the
works
yeah and got the thing we used to call
20 minutes or less it's yeah we have
yeah I think and I think there's also
different segments to that show or it's
like we do different things like he does
a lot of pop culture stuff Joe does
feeling good we do stupid versus stupid
and then we do head to head and
I'll gather on nerdy kind of stuff be
close commentary is another one-on-one
yeah we're testing out a new show that's
actually pretty cool called table time
yeah talk so the short answer is we
don't know a lot a dozen
yeah and I feel like there's always
still stuff in the works too like yeah
came that day when I go on try this out
there's always still stuff there
bribery mostly yeah trust fund money
that I just dumped out no I
I auditioned back we all audition yeah
well except my dad is a millionaire and
he knows people and he had me oh five of
you auditioned to at the same time maybe
you should these guys all auditioned at
the same time and then like a month
later I auditioned mhm and then like six
months later I yeah we all went through
a process to an audition together I
remember reading with every single one
of them I remember Steve said something
about spanking it yeah in my first
audition women Lee touched
I touched everybody yeah and then I
remember Elliott have been so tall next
to me that I was like from what I
understand Phil and James and and the
other people involved in the production
of the show before it started went
through at least seven seven thousand
seven thousand different possible hosts
through and they watched over 75 Wiley
coyote yeah we watched or every now and
then we'll like stumble upon like old
videos and there's still like there or
like the very first before we started
actually airing SourceFed like because
we had a few weeks where we were
prepping oh and good lord there so maybe
we won't give you a sneak peak of them
yeah see you guys you guys are always
like do not even mention
audition tapes yeah those tapes exist
like this it's like they're more
embarrassing I think it's funny that
we're calling yeah tapes tapes they're
in here somewhere let's go look at it
tapes what else would you call them
though audition files yeah files exist
footage JPEG you know the auditions okay
listen I wasn't really we one didn't
expect it yeah if you watch the footage
every every reaction is a hundred
percent real because we practice our
losing faces if we lose this is gonna be
hilarious it's ready we were like ready
like I'm holy Steven churches hands and
you're like ready to be really dramatic
and that's not a joke like we only
talked about what we would do if we lost
like now we absolutely did not plan win
it at all again and you know not that we
were like oh we suck but it was just
like we just felt like we there were so
many great people being nominated yeah
and there's so many great shows yeah
yeah it's also just like a testament to
our freakin viewers yeah we were
nominated for four words Awards but we
were talking about if we could just win
one this is the one that we won yeah
very cool and the streamys was so like
that was the first award ceremony I've
ever really been to and and to be a part
of it like to go write maybe someday
I'll be able to enjoy one but like just
to go to my part to go to my first award
show and actually be in it and be a part
of it it was such a like a crazy new
experience it was really cool and then
meeting everyone in our field meeting
all those peers all those people that
make content on YouTube and the internet
it was just awesome you're a two feet
away from Larry King yeah why oh they
smell been getting Marina marina marina
we didn't even we had press to do
backstage and Joe refused to leave until
Vanilla Ice was done yeah not a lot
there's nothing like one percent truth
and I feel it was a 10 percent shame to
see Vanilla Ice perform live really
amazing there we go it was good a bit
but really it was our it's our fans I
mean it was audience choice for reason
and it's the our fans voted more than
your fans award and I think we all have
a sense of humor and I think that's a
real big part of it yeah also we're all
actors like we like each other not at
all I know like beginning cuz me Joe and
we never knew each other prior to
auditioning or starting but then we
really after we started we started
carpooling together and you can only
wake up at like 4:30 a.m. so many weeks
in a row before you start getting to
know each other really well we yeah we
just spent a lot of time together yeah
also I think so much of our day is based
around like because we all have a
fantastic senses of humor if I could say
so myself all of our kind of
relationships are definitely based
around humor also and I think that we
just we all get each other in our weird
jokes and stuff and that helps you guys
you guys remember Jake he didn't get our
humor that we stoned no no I don't think
I'd be shaggy yeah I've already figured
that out
no you're good I've already figured this
out okay let me take it hard
okay Steve you're scooby-doo okay Joe
you're shagging really yeah you're Fred
I don't I don't it's gonna be Velma I
feel like you would be Fred no you're
sure
in fairness I haven't seen scooby-doo in
ever I'm okay with the friend shaggy
Scooby I feel like okay
Elma yeah Daphne Velma your son I'm
scrappy-doo yah yah yah yah no I am Fred
you're right your friend he's totally
shaggy
I think we're sweet already figured it's
not that I'm a better scooby-doo no he's
a little shaggy
I'm the van I'm the hotel kids she'll
make any sense yeah why do people always
dress up go scare people away for like
sometimes I was you know we absolutely
do Tricia and I did Thanksgiving
together this yeah we took the turkey
and everything oh you did well I guess
the Jo you said that you were spent
Thanksgiving alone this year no no I'm
true yeah we did Ollie time we're
skateboards out we go down to the ball
see you later get some honey
yes favorite thing is him in one of our
producers Matthew Bowman will drive by
them all and then ask people who are
sitting outside of the mall do you know
where the mall
and I'm always in the backseat like that
time I went to the Museum of Tolerance
together yeah oh good remember how Ellie
would not stop crying oh my mom said my
mother said I was really glad that you
were wearing so much clothing
and my dad was just like well dream big
you know they're both really super
supportive and amazing they always have
been so but they were just like okay and
but they were both very very happy that
I had so much clothing on just like you
were you were the one that had the most
clothing our parents were my parents
it's really funny to me when the parents
get in on the show when like my mom will
call me like it Steve okay today never
met Steve she just knows from repeated
viewings of the show she feels like she
knows everyone my mom one time said Joe
seems like a good guy least of all you
Steve least of all that's my dark next
question yeah yeah it's been a weird I
think that's been a weird transition to
like I don't cuz I'm always like is that
person what do I have on my face like
that's always what I think like what do
I have on my face what am I wearing did
I step in something and I'm like oh
thank God cuz I thought I am mentally
prepared for any type of fan interaction
up until the point of fan interaction hi
you're Joe Bereta yeah
who are you I'm Jake I shake hands and
then I'm I don't know where to go I'm
gonna come off like a jerk so I come off
like I think oh really excited and
creepy yeah hey hi all right I'm not
mean I love you okay okay one of my
favorite meeting a fan of public
experiences was
subway and the guy working at the
counter like recognized swordsmen I was
like yeah man he's man he kept talking
to me and and all the other people in
the restaurant we're like looking like
who is this guy like this guy is not
this guy can't be nobody recognized me
except this one guy and that's how
you're holding up the line no it's it's
funny because I dated somebody who got
recognized odd so now when people
recognize me I'm like DiCaprio was kind
of a jerk I know the best one for me was
when someone came up to me and said you
look just like Trisha Hershberger I was
like the weirdest you go oh my gosh who
is that no I was that I was working at
an Auto Show so I had a name tag on
that's it Trisha nervous covering it and
I went no I did we took a picture yeah
and then Elliott said some some guy in
his mid-50s that was my first one yeah
this is like right after summer spent
started he leans over and he goes big
fan of SourceFed and I go thank you and
then we rode the whole elevator I hug
immediately cuz that's what I do then
I'm a ends are just hugging and I was
like it's just too long oh it's just way
too long I gotta get out of this and
then I like got out of the hug and I saw
some lady with a video can't like I'm on
her phone her but she's like just
recording and choose who are you hugging
someone inappropriately to on oh this
one does all of you want to give it
gratitude yeah into too much detail but
there why just me my favorite one
someone did tweet me that said someday
your
will suck clocks and Hills like the
iPhone autocorrect really got them sigh
retweeted I get my mom also texted me to
say I don't know why I would suck so
many clocks in hell it's really not my
personal hell I don't know what happened
I really enjoyed I'm a big fan of all
types of Klaus
the grandfather pocket digital I love
them all we're weird
well I'm Hispanic so I'll let your mind
wander on that one
well what does that mean he didn't think
this through anything that's true it was
that and not being creative if I wasn't
in the entertainment industry I'd
probably be some kind of teacher Wow I
think it's something that I'll do after
all of this yeah I don't know I uh I
went to school to do everything and then
didn't finish anything so yeah I
probably either a masseuse masseuse try
be a masseuse wait see a lot of that
worked out yeah I mean I guess I'd be a
masseuse I could be my personal
assistant now honestly I'd probably be a
hair stylist because you know why not or
a teacher because I didn't want to be a
teacher growing up and then no yeah oh
my god can you marry people for that guy
yeah I'd probably marry someone rich me
too but in addition to that probably an
animal hospital so it's good any
problems like Elliott yes my dog has
this thing limited very vague
information my dog ate a double-a
battery what do I do
wait
okay good no just kidding good go to the
um I always thought about being like
that crazy math teacher that wears the
turtleneck with like the square root of
devotion signs all over it and like
overalls and I could news me any normal
teacher I'd have to be like the crazy
algebra teacher that article um I went
to college to get my teaching degree in
history so I probably be a history
teacher somewhere I also worked at
deviantART which was fun
so probably they're the team of teachers
that's why we do the new my teaching
career is just an excuse for me to coach
basketball cuz I think I'd be an amazing
coach out there wouldn't each other so
much I could not every time between this
and this diagram guess what goes in
there so much fun see you tomorrow fired
see a practice
you